good afternoon everybody welcome to my
comer and Friends play the peeper be
play the people here at the Chess Club
get your challenges in right now let's
see if you can beat Mike yes it's all
gonna be rated challenges if you do
casual you're out you're off the grid
let's try to keep a look at New Deal
right off the bat neo you're off the bat
and next time Neil do you come up I'm
asking you out no matter what
alright let's try to keep the challenges
to five minutes or less yeah yeah
especially 301 Oh yep yep and we have a
very special thing going on today tell
us about this Mike yes yes we will be
doing a drawing for the $1,000 national
chest day intense just Invitational so
we'll be drawing the pairings out of
this and the seeds
Jonathan schranz Julian Pro LICO Grand
Master Ken West will all be part of that
guy and we'll have Pepe doing the color
commentary ball who probably not okay it
starts with the seat
anyway so we'll be doing the join live
at 4:20 today and national chess day is
of course October 12th
all right so Patrick Daly has a 3o
standard so thank you so we are like are
you gonna play or we're playing see if I
have no matter what matter what no
matter what and now he's in the Caledon
court all right a gallon in court not a
place you want to be a catch it clearly
not a place where you want to be this
guy only Yasir Sarah knows how to beat
the Kalin in court so if I play awesome
Sarah and I'm not gonna play the
cowlings I am gonna play that I might as
well just pre move
and now a big trick big trick he thinks
that I'm coming here I have no intention
of coming there so he has to blow the a3
move and whenever they play e4 you just
knew they're gonna play four and then
you just take cast
now what take when he does there's
nobody can resist on pussycat
it's like irresistible oh no he saw
somehow he resisted oh but he did anyway
figure it out all right all right we got
a mulligan through we got a mulligan
now we're praying for a knight takes
button he didn't go for it
maybe I should up well well let's attack
all his Knights attack them attack them
attack way ahead on time looking I'm a
2074 now I really come a long way
open the G file up for them open the G
file for the man you know what I'll give
here in my pawn you want my pawn you got
it buddy you got it your group on free
pawn take the bait my all right well
we'll see how it goes from here pan it
and win it that's what they say it's
what they say all right what's going on
well we could attack it again but then
they just retreat or he could play oh I
could take the war it could play Knight
takes tactics master of tactics right
there that's what they call them you
could play Bishop a6 here but then I can
also fork his rook so yeah this guy
doesn't know what's going on I told you
we're gonna do that I told you you were
gonna do that all as a triple gotta move
why oh he's got he's got a little check
coming oh but I could throw in this
check
dude you're you're way behind you're way
behind on this game okay throw I'll
throw in the spite check I'll throw in
the spike check oh yes this couldn't
work out better that couldn't have
worked out better a crushing Patrick
Daly with my expert chess rating no he's
not he's not not a friend of mine he's
just nada got it come you know who he is
I don't know mr. Daly he sounds like it
yeah this is almost resigning he's just
down a look for nothing it's in the
Caledon court the Caledon court comes
through we have three coming how many of
you got any viewers we got any of yours
guy let's see yeah we have 63 people
watching how many 63 it's a lot of
people that's a lot a see who's AC oh
and here comes the big check just to
bring it home with a big check
that was my theme for the day right
don't get checked and he's down to 17
seconds yeah just give it up yeah black
is victorious oh look at this guy's
SCC corals South Carolina Carl maybe
he's gonna try to become a chess expert
not on my watch buddy you want some of
the Cal in court oh yeah he learned he
learned he didn't want nothing to do
with the Calladine Court who talked to
that line Michael there's some video
they all like the only chest video I
ever watched it was an actual DVD foxy
openings that was cold he remembers it
look at this guy I know all the lines in
the Calladine court god this guy is
trying to become a chess expert and this
is what he brings to the table all right
so you really want to check me huh you
really really want to check me sometimes
you just got to let it happen
[Laughter]
all right hey hey - you could play this
game - yeah we're going for we're going
for it go ahead go ahead go ahead give
me a check oh yeah oh but that oh no you
still can't take my night check me
anyway you want to
he's got a couple options than me I'm
sure you got something up your sleeve
though Michael
yeah ninety-two Chuck that's all I got
going for alright alright now the moment
of truth do I want to go here or there I
guess I'll go alright Perea proof Perry
up pre-approved move seems to be a
little more formidable than you thought
Michael no just keep putting on the
pressure keep putting the pressure on
give up a rook to get a lot and we're
lifetime one an O against us see Carl so
we've got that over we got Doris well he
took it he took a big mistake rook for
rook huh
rook rook but you have better
developments if you say so I mean nice
way down there oh my gosh this is this
guy a joker just lost his queen
Jamie discovery no he can walk check
yeah that was so silly because I could I
can obviously get a draw here if if so
be except your knight is pinned at the
moment oh how did dad have checkmate
okay checkmate just say it's checkmate
[Laughter]
you got one move buddy you got one move
Hey
no what's the follow-through hmm oh is
my king in a pin the whole time
all right sounds good Mike yeah it
wasn't good move it wasn't this back it
up back it up back it up all right
now just got a trap let's get this night
going this is longer we don't lose on
time we'll be fine
watch this boom Chuck yeah oh but then
he's got a check Oh son of a gun he's
gotta get out of check first
no no yeah take that bishop down there
I've seen you have your king be a
warrior Mike yep I've seen you do it not
afraid he's not afraid you do it he's
not afraid I'm not gonna lose on time
that's what that's what that's that's my
okay better better kick it up then yeah
let's kick it up let's kick it okay now
watch this I'm gonna box that guy in
boxing minute
get up get up he's got you a little bit
on time by about 15 seconds 12 13
seconds figure it up
he doesn't more pieces than you know
ever that's fine well
what's going on Danny what's going on
I'm in check
always with the check this guy what what
happened I don't know what's going on we
went back in time Danny oh man maybe
I'll check made them anyway maybe I'll
check made them anyway here Dan the
screen keeps going blank Danny
[Music]
yeah I was up one away from a stalemate
here time out white is victorious yeah
if it wasn't for that second glitch
technical okay let's get rid of these
casual ones militar axon abort I was
just joking around I just joking around
militar you should've got to do standard
you got a deuce raided that's the
clients boring for calling us boring
Michael oh my god alright looking at the
calling that's boring
what do you what do you need what do you
need he wants Yaser and Jenner you can't
have it all you can't have it was boring
you guys are boring where's Jen Yasser
and the big guy in the big big guy and
the big guy all right let's play a
little one-minute action here what
happened to a lost game against military
would a military clean okay oh my god a
minute game holy cow
holy cow maybe this will excite Kerry
would say
look at this hot action here that's a
chess club yeah remove that defender
Mike remove the defender
move the defender well it's temporarily
removed Chuck
yep my big guy there's nothing I can do
about it thank you jack oh yeah I can
always check them to recomm that's a
good move
thank you that was a very nice move who
saved your queen and I'm gonna win whoa
let's the first take and then watch this
tactic yeah
master tactics right here tactician here
and he doesn't know why he can't take
that's the funniest part of this games
about over it's never over it's never
till it's over till the fat lady sings
don't they say yep Michael grabbed hold
of the G file
I need that G
the master master controller here yes
check them check enlarge check them just
for fun just for fun come just for fun
I got it look I got a lot of parts like
a pen with you do have a lot of pods but
he's not gonna do it cuz he's got two
seconds left those games over good now
we'll start the second was that one
enough for ya Roos Br okay I'll slow it
down a little bit
three minutes three minutes plus two
seconds like again with the c5 no matter
what alright everybody if you guys are
coming up for the Friday extra quads
tomorrow keep in mind there is the
balloon glow going on Michaels Friday
Friday yeah if you are coming up for the
Friday expose her like you said tomorrow
well the taste we're all the time right
go ahead
we've coming in for the Friday night
action quads tonight what's going on be
sure be sure to come in early what's
going on we have the balloon glow also
going on right at 7 o'clock and what is
the balloon glow it's in Forest Park
it's where they light up a bunch of
balloons but everybody's so enamored by
them that you'll want to come early if
you are not present at 7:00 I might just
give you a half-point buy or pair you
with somebody that is also late tonight
so oh so your concern that people will
be Lakers are watching the balloon glow
right no there's a heavy heavy traffic
along king's highway or highway 40 sure
so get here early guys for the finite
action quad if you come advice and also
tomorrow the actual festivities
festivities of the balloon race sort at
noon tomorrow the st. Louis district
that's right one of our best best
tournaments for the public of the year
over $4,000 that's right I'm gonna have
to go to the bank or maybe Dennis LaRue
if you're watching someone cut your
check already that's somebody I know cut
my check okay but actually there's a big
difference between cutting a check well
let's cut it so it's cut it's cut so I
have to run to the bank yeah maybe if
Dennis Luebbe was watching he can go
cash
and do a little banking of his own all
right we got going on all right
well yeah probably after this game by pi
we'll have to take a brief break all
right cash make a big big cash all right
tumble after I get back on the road to
2008 and I'm not taking no minute Gabey
I'll get lucky risk go down here to help
me out Danny can be give me some moves
from remember this is a team effort here
at the st. Louis chess club always at
always a team effort this is bad okay
what does that mean sue Lee lol this is
bad
I drew the guy next to Mike and chess
well that's quite an accomplishment
right yeah quite an accomplishment I
don't know who you are but I'm sure I'm
lucky I didn't lose let's put it that
way
you know Michael how do I play versus
Mike so you gotta go challenge on Lee
chess
all right so they just go to leech s and
then click on st. Louis Chess Club they
can challenge right if you say so it's
that easy it's that easy
there's a link in the chat got it oh you
just put it all you just put it in there
all right
click on the link it's that easy it's
that easy we have eight challenges in
the queue and obviously if you guys are
wondering what is in this box if you
have just joined us we are going to have
on October 12th that is national chess
day we will have $1,000 national chess
day intense chest invitational
tournament with all the youtube stars of
the chest community including Jonathan
shrines Julian poll eco Ken West Dennis
LaRue right Arjun Puri
alright I was the first teacher adjourn
so yeah it's good masters in there just
Ken was okay but we will have a
grandmaster commentator Pepe
hey cuenca yes yes so and if you want to
know what intense chess is it's the
greatest game ever invented co-created
by myself and Jonathan shruts and we
want to tell us what it involves my
thing I'm just let him up like try to go
over in their own minds yeah try to be
mystery are you gonna tell them what a
game one minute
oh I just lost this game that's alright
you weren't concentrating game one
minute with a 10 second delay I just
resigned so or I tried to resign oh I
think I don't think you resign it's
still going my game oh they're not
letting me resign they're like cuz I'm
about ready to lose my row maybe I maybe
I can go get my Guinness night somehow
some point probably not maybe I'll just
get rid of all my pieces real quick here
hey well I tried to resign they didn't
let me present maybe they have a no
resign button on here I don't know but
whatever I'm not resigning I'm just
gonna play on maybe I'll play f4 and
then I'll win this guy I don't know who
knows stranger things have happened
- good - resign he says mr. show sting
ms/ms show sting says we're shifting but
shifting I glad you have confidence than
me maybe I'll get a stalemate out of
this anyway we'll see see how it goes
but with the two second increments kind
of difficult
look it twice
he doesn't know where I'm going well no
one ever dies no oh he got his he got
his thing off the thing up oh shoot he's
got one spot for his don't look to go to
I guess I maybe I should have let him
play King of three first I got fortress
I'm in a fortress if I say I'm in a
fortress I'm in a fortress I mean you
don't try to play Bishop d4 at some
point aren't you I already played Bishop
d4 that comeback is officially on oh my
gosh can i like win8 you I told you not
to resign
my camera is very best yep an activator
Dinaric no big deal no big dancer rook I
mean you know oh my god yes sir and his
pawn is hanging on the beef hi oh no his
Bishop is hanging on this exchange
bill oh this is too late that's right
I'm not watching live this is way way
that's right
oh you've totally caught up Michael
and the only down two points don't like
to kind of fill and you're down in time
so you move gotta move I gotta move
gotta move gotta move down on time but
quite a comeback quite a comeback and I
got to pass spawns now you do and you
can then erase that a pawn to victory or
maybe the HBase one's a little bit
closer this is true this is true just go
fast whatever you do Michael no I do not
have to go fast well you have 17 seconds
left that's that's an eternity oh you
did not want to go up there this could
be one of epic comebacks there it is
it's official epic combat could be epic
come back here this could be one for the
ages right here they try to resign twice
my pressure is I press the blood and
Troy down ten points and now he's gonna
come back with two with victory watch
this I use got abyss
oh that's alright go fast
there it is what a move this guy cannot
be stopped
cannot be stopped this guy's gotta feel
like what what a comeback come on Mike
seal the deal 11 seconds to go come on
nine seconds Noah did not want to go
there
hey go somewhere go so don't get you
don't get your queen for it don't know I
know all about forking try to get him on
a black square
at that comeback epoch you can't no more
checks there to no more checks mr. rook
this game is just about over a couple
more moves it's over checkmate is
unavoidable at this point good night
Irene oh you missed your checkmate
Thank You mr. checkmate you would think
I missed a checkmate it's over
great comeback what an epic comes oh
let's it come and see how kept ik when
after a night takes even check I'm King
f8 Knight takes c6 almost as good as
look at that +8 almost down by wow yeah
and then and then the Oilers scored
right off the bat to start that to start
the second half mm-hmm so they're down
35 that's right right and about 38 35
right yep yep so it's like that you
never give up never surrender never
precise because you can't resign I tried
to press the button so that three best
points I ever got all right I've got to
go to the bank collect all my winnings
from that big of big victory hands I
mean I have to play okay you gotta
follow that yeah it's gonna be that's
gonna be rough we got you at risk Oh
down here and you need some five-o
challenge yes but we will be doing the
big drawing of the of the lots at 4:20
Central time today so in about 40
minutes be back to watch that the
drawing see where Julian play see where
Jonathan plays oh the international
arbiter / I'll be I'll be up there with
the mic yep since Ben Simon is
preoccupied on national chest day
okay all right all right people here we
go oh my gosh look at this we have 16
challenges 15 challenges okay
trying to get the challenges here see
that Danny
we have some kind of connection problem
or something Danny I'll refresh it all
right there we go all right
a guy 3 2 oh my god that's awful fast
but we'll give it a chance we'll give it
a shot
all right we will give it a shot
all right so the Kings Indian hmm
been trying to get better at this one
all right
I don't get anything here it's okay
okay
not quite as loud without Michael here
okay a guy what are you from a guy
all right stick the soap and file
Oh
[Music]
quite the battle here
[Music]
ah damn it
darn it
oh well they loved beating the chess
club don't they but remember you're
playing me not the Chess Club let's see
if we can do come on you're a head of a
whole ruck dude
hmm yeah it's bad news bad bad news good
game good game a five minute game how
about a five minute game no casual games
all right there we go
newb Frank were you from your move
he's not even online so we're just gonna
abort this game find a new game five
minute game five minutes hey Danny why
can't I see his writing 15 or something
it's going okay five minutes three not
yet but we're working on it
we're working on it oh yeah we're gonna
try I need you in here for some moral
support Danny we don't like this line I
think it's okay so far yeah yeah so
we're just gonna Jack his queen because
I can why not okay
[Music]
yes good yeah guy 99 oh my gosh all
right what do we got here
guy 99 words guy 99 from Nick risco I'm
calling Nick risk Oh calm down
he's upstairs yeah
oh he's got the Deaf by himself okay we
need some help I'm not getting crushed
quite yet he's got this going on just
making me a little nervous
seen the ideas Danny depending on what
he does I suppose cuz remember you're
playing it's a team effort here at the
Chess Club that's right that's right
and Danny Machuca well Danny can do both
Danny is so talented
danny is so talented that he can make
moves and produce the show at the same
time that's how much talent Danny
Machuca has in him I don't know somebody
someone shadow I'm not alright no one's
hearing me no you okay
can they hear what I'm saying okay but
someone chatted if they don't know who
I'm talking to
I'm just talking to I'm just talking to
the audience and I'm just guys just like
hey every every every every second that
ticks down oh there he goes
okay well I'm gonna take so I take Danny
all right I'll take all right I'm not
the best I'm not the best
okay
Queen is under attack so let's get it
out of attack not gonna be okay
I think that's okay we'll find out in a
second here
well I got to check make this guy
yeah I got it right here can you hear
check check all right all right guy 99
I'd love to get a victory love to get a
victory for the
it's never easy winning a chess game
oh heavens to salmon's to Betsy
okay
so if I take he has a discovery can he
take my queen I don't think so
I take
does not have a discovery you can check
me okay I guess I'll take the bait you
can check me sure he's got something
devious plan
no no that's right no there that's right
well should I go Danny
live on h6 and we live on h6 that's
right and then he'll check me all right
probably lost well we'll see
very strong I shouldn't have I shouldn't
have taken that with my queen okay let's
find someone we can win oh of casual
player he's too tough oh my oMG you're
such a creep alright let's try to get
one for the one for the team
it's your move
are you gonna make a move I don't want
to bore it too many games alright
yeah that's we got here all right let's
play this one AB de Sonya okay here he
goes
my comers in the house I am alright be
back in live live action alright
hopefully I get one victory before you
come back
who's laughing in there is that Jesse
let's see you come here and play let's
see you play okay leave that open it's
nice breeze all right well I would have
put a door blocker because it'll slam or
shot in that to close set all right hey
Michael all right
I have to win at least one game
yeah
all right
awful quiet here without Michel awful
quiet
awful quiet indeed
um I think I might win an exchange maybe
just ate it Danny don't struggle
shoulders stuff it's real tough I'm
taking it I'm taking it all right all
right all right now what okay what's
this guy's concerning me right here
what's he got he's got here he's got
here all right I gotta move can you
check me
you know what I've been playing better
I've been playing yes they are
[Music]
I've seen Jessie been doing some
training Jessie been doing some training
yeah good you what's on the calendar
this is
not to convince you to come on there yes
I might have a tactic might have a
tactic yes
can he help me with some moves
all right
it's one over one game I just want to
win one game just one no he can't I've
lost - lost - all right I like a little
dr. evil the dog can't poke her head out
mr. bigglesworth white he's on white and
I'm on blue he can't even like anyone to
check me here he would go tiny dog
all right double attack nope that'll
hang a queen we don't want to do that no
I need up that's my specialty thirty
hanging clean yeah I can hang with the
best of them mm-hmm how about their
attacks tonight looks all right
please God it looks safe enough at least
what is that all right
oh no that's all right Queens gone so
we'll take this Queen okay there we go
looks gone okay well what we're
consolidating all right all right all
right I don't think that looks bad I
don't know what that means don't face
the dog the other way now all right Oh
quick Wow pawned gun mypods car which
fun
the the year which won the a pond he's
gonna take you oh yes isn't it uh right
oh you know he's gonna take you with a
check up Harry I check in with your
bishop
[Music]
I grabbed gills
all right all right
there you go oh well yeah yeah yeah ah
my Bishop's gonna cause me grief
yeah there you go
do it unless you can skirt around his
bishop somehow
[Music]
mmm locked up as a draw as he Flags you
know oh boy oh boy I gave a quite a
battle man yeah all right good game you
gonna play Jesse yeah play one right you
gonna coach you from the side - sure
although I'm not a very good coach
what's Mike's cover fireman
yeah okay here's the start of the show
Mike um oh I was just a filling
oh no that twelve challenges all right
we're all about to get lessened any
coach all right cuz my comer so talented
and we have this is Zia Zia Zia the
chest dog she's met all the famous chess
stars whether they wanted to or not we
almost drew you mean just like that
watch me fumble around my very best all
right I'm gonna try that out all right
what are we playing one of those
challenges here yeah make sure it's
raided oh boy well I don't know we're
gonna keep we'll do it okay okay
you're right so I don't know if Perry
gave this gentleman uh-oh
proper introductory right this is Jesse
uh our I won't say your last name
Richardson our IT specialist over at the
Chess Club yeah and Mike comer will just
yell out whenever I make a whenever I
make a horrible blunder so far so solid
I'm like not what I would recommend but
yeah we're three in the world
it'll be unconventional see there was
three moves in you prevents a three
alright so now it's time to get your
other pieces in the action your knight
and your LightSquared bishop hey there
you go I just copy off to that guy and
you see you have the advantage because
you see your dark square bishop is out
and his light square bishop is out some
locked in all right so now I just
removed that Bishop to a square that it
can't lose oh okay all right move the
other light square bishop you're also
developed the light square bishop okay
there you go
like that is safe what we're he's safe
hopefully doing some good work it's
challenging you each challenge your
bishop you don't want double pawns so
you can just take it or pin the night
mmm let's go ahead and take yeah take it
I like that way you can't lose it now
you can just castle the safety something
I never do but I'm learning all right
we're getting there we're getting there
all right from there let's try and this
is where it becomes chest okay they were
players of chess replace a big-league
chess all right so so far so solid for
Jesse Richardson Queen in the fight here
huh now you asked what we have here we
will be doing the drawing of the lats at
420 so in about five minutes we'll be
doing the drawing of the lats for the
$1,000 national chest day intense chest
invitational so the invited ones GM can
mystery man all right you didn't never
know who that's gonna be
Julian Pro Lika world champion Julian
pearl eco of the st. Louis Archbishop's
Oh Jacob Sanders Oh Oh Julian play again
alright Michael Pugachev Oh Dennis LaRue
a blunder a blunder adjourn or as I call
him ad journ hurry and none other than
Jonathan shruts Oh we'll mix them up
really good I'll mix them up good get
them in the box and see so it's gonna be
a 8 player so one plays eight and what
are we drawing lots for the $1,000
national Geste intense just Invitational
so the winner gets $500 cash and also
Pepe will be doing the commentary oh
really
so it should be fun alongside Caleb
Denby alright alright so it should be a
fun time don't take that
I don't what what's the what's the trap
here what am I looking at that night
takes your coin oh yeah that would that
would be a bummer okay now you just just
throw the night up there and attack the
bish up up the g5 we're just gonna try
to checkmate them now that's your only
chance the game's called checkmate great
so he'll move is bishop and then you can
swing the rook right over to h3 and just
try to checkmate them somehow some way
oh yeah
is that's the name of the game checkmate
all right Knight though he's attacking
your pawn so you can just protect that
pawn with your C pawn he's attacking oh
yeah yep good good good pic and then
we're gonna try to checkmate online I
each seven here somehow
oh oil again I guess we care retreat to
a safe square mmm there's only one safe
looking square we're running out of safe
squares which is usually the case oh boy
Oh with the pot with what's the deal if
I take with the Queen if I take with the
Queen well if you take with the part you
can put your king on h1 your work on f3
and our work on g1 and checkmate them
that way
take I've always got to try to checkmate
them at this point so take with the pawn
and then what's the idea from here move
your king to h1 and you're up to - oh
but he's threatening a fork here but
this is good he's threatening to play
Knight to f4 forking your rook and your
guy working your queen so play your
queen up to e4 right there 1 2 3 4 got
it and we almost have a chance here
believe it or not cuz see how his rooks
aren't playing yeah they're hanging back
yep
so if we could checkmate them his works
are useless they're like in a fault
like like you know they're like just
cash reserves for when he's 65 we can't
make them get to 65 ok all right here we
go here we go now our plan is on we
don't care about that plan yeah did your
king - h1 okay and why I don't know why
are we moving the Keane h1 so good look
on the g1 put our rook to d1 right now
we don't care about that other pawn
pawns are meaningless at this point all
right and then just send them skyward
okay okay okay
all right here we go
take I would take that pawn now do you
take the take the C pawn quickly and
then when he takes with the knight will
play Queen to g4
to the white square who to the whites /
yep you got it you got 27 seconds so you
got to play fast we got to checkmate
them right here right now we're
threatening Rick takes h6 rook no no
that well why we what I lost anyway but
it could have had a we could have made
it up should have made it something I
totally messed up where that idea was
okay he defended well he defended well
now you just get rid of all your pieces
and pray for stalemate yep no you just
move your puns quickly yep as far as
they can go
I moved it move the other part and now
move that other pawn yep and now pray
for stalemate Oh No dun dun dun dun dun
dun dun er nice to try nice try
alright thank you for the game alright
and now it's time for the drawing of the
last what we've all been waiting for
right we're gonna do it this Z and n
style you want to be around for this
yeah sure alright you ready for this
Danny alright so the dog can verify that
I mix these are so good alright here we
go here where you go watch his hands
like my hands
all right ready go there you go
I'll get them in or get them on they're
doing one little nice shake shake all
right and now to make an official we
will shake the box furiously all right
you're shaking it all right and now we
have 1 through 8 7 they're all there
they're all there there's four there's
two okay I'll mix them up a little bit
yep yeah we got we got the official are
valid it was not one that dogs are ever
to my game I'd be very very scared
all right so now you got this you got em
all mixed up and now we will do a big
shake all right all right so this is
just I'll see you then did it so all
right so here we go the number one oh
the number one pick will be get that the
number one see all right and number one
seed will get white in all the game so
remember this is Game one with a
ten-second delay the $1,000 national
chest day Invitational intense chest
invitational Game one get one minute and
then you get ten seconds delay so
basically you think on that that ten
seconds is your action clock and then
you know if you fall past that minute
you're gonna go under your time bank
which is just one minute okay so number
one seed who is it gonna be who is it
gonna be
Jonathan shrine around this your hands
the club manager gets the number one
seat and also with the number one seed
if you're the higher rated seed and if
it's a draw
then we'll go straight to an Armageddon
match where White will start with two
seconds and a 10 second delay black will
only have one second and a 10 second
play you might think well that's not
really a big difference but it really is
because basically if it goes one to zero
you're done if it goes 2 to 1 you get
like basically 1 Mulligan and can hit
the clock real quick and black would get
draws on that one so ok so if we're
keeping that track at home one is
Jonathan and all right now we'll go on
the 8th seed so this will actually be
who Jonathan will be playing in the
first round perfect mix them up good
adjourn hurry all right so what a big
matchup we have two of the best players
in the event playing right off the bat
and that will come ll start right at 7
o'clock on national chess day which is
October 12 so if you want to see
Jonathan with the white pieces against
the church you better click in right at
the start all right next up look number
4 so that will be in this bracket so in
case number one plays 8 we will advance
to see who number 4 is
none other than Dennis LaRue all right
hey see what's going on here oh and it's
number five so this is actually who
Dennis Lee we will be playing thirty
five so let's see right off the bat who
libera will be playing it looks like
it's gonna be Pugachev so big rematch
from LaRue against pugachev so
Pugachev was up - OH on LaRue and
couldn't seal the deal so maybe he can
get his vengeance today all right so now
we have one side of the bracket all set
up
Jonathan against adjourn will be playing
the winner of LaRue against Pugachev
LaRue will have the white pieces all
right all up to the next bracket here
number two all right number two so this
is the second most valuable spot so
let's see who's gonna get number two
Julian Pro Rico national master world
champion of the st. Louis Archbishop's
has the second seed let's see who will
be playing
no he will be playing somebody with the
seventh seat all right let's see let's
see who we get do we get - we got shake
it up real nice and good here Jacob
Matthew Sanders who defeated Dennis
LaRue and a big glitz find so that could
be a possible championship if he can
make it through Julien but good luck
good luck kid
all right the last seed goes to
Grandmaster Ken West All Right see what
seed he'll get it looks like he'll get
it's only it's either three or six three
or six the feeling lucky is he feels
lucky is he gets number three which
means obviously number six goes to who
who is the last man on the scene he's
got a really big piece of paper on
yeah someone else so now let's just say
it's a mystery man
we ran out the papers papers can you
believe it I only invited seven people
to an 8-man event can you believe all
right well roll the graphics all right
there you go you got Jonathan Trent's
with number one against adjourn Dennis
LaRue has white against Pugachev maybe
Pugachev can get his revenge national
master Julian against Jacob Sanders and
Grand Master Kayne West who knows maybe
he'll play another Grandmaster
the mystery man so please tune in
October 12th 7 o'clock central short
Caleb Danby and Pepe will be doing the
live commentary Eric down here I'll be
upstairs with the microphone you know
doing impromptu interviews Nicolas risco
will be doing the dgt a machine unless
you want to come in on Saturday night I
thought you said mr. Nick was gonna be
doing deejaying will have that blasted
again it's gonna be a lot of fun
national chess day one thousand dollars
up for grabs
hopefully everybody can join in and
we'll invite somebody with their eights
thing that will be one of our youtube
stars okay good night everybody